When you think about the money studios pour
into your favorite films, it isn't a shocker
that they may need to occasionally reuse a
prop or a costume.
Still, it can be jarring to see some of these
outfits, which have been made famous once
already in classic films, pop up again on
some random extra wandering around in the
background.
Here are a few times movies got caught recycling
costumes.
Dress for success
Who can forget that fabulous purple dress
Clara Clayton wore as she, Doc Brown, and
their two weirdo kids ended the Back to the
Future trilogy by heading out on the ultimate
family road trip?
Well, it looks like she donated the dress
to a Goodwill somewhere along the way — because
the character of Shannon in 1992's Far and
Away came across the exact same dress in a
Boston storefront.
And just knew she had to have it.
But while some dresses get to travel through
time, others just can't catch a break.
That's one shipwrecked dress
After surviving the RMS Titanic's collision
with an iceberg in the 1996 TV miniseries
Titanic, this little black number on actress
Marilu Henner found itself right back on the
doomed passenger liner.
This time it was worn by actress Tricia O'Neil
in the Oscar-winning 1997 blockbuster Titanic.
Talk about a dress that needs a vacation — preferably
one that doesn't end at the bottom of the
sea.
Of course, that's not the only outfit to survive
the Neptune's wet grasp...
Jacket Everlasting
Garments don't get much more famous than this
pink jacket worn by Kate Winslet in 1997's
Titanic, which sold at auction in 2016 for
over $160,000 and was actually made into a
doll.
And yet even this iconic outfit was recycled.
It popped up again, slightly altered, in the
2002 fantasy film Tuck Everlasting.
Look guys, that jacket has a family to feed.
No judgments.
Helping Peggy
As we've figured out by now, period outfits
often get reused again and again.
If something works for one 1960s series, it'll
probably work just as well for a movie set
in the same timeframe.
That was certainly the case with this pink
frock, which Elisabeth Moss wore in the Mad
Men episode "Three Sundays," only for it to
pop up again in the 2011 movie The Help, this
time worn by Anna Camp.
The hat of a hero
There's always a need for foppish hats, right?
Whether you're a musketeer, a pirate, or just
a guy who happens to like looking good.
This dandy number first popped up in the 2001
flop The Musketeer, worn by future Grey's
Anatomy star Justin Chambers.
Later, the hat weaved its way through the
Hollywood backlots and onto the magnificent
mane of Orlando Bloom for the 2003 smash hit
Pirates of the Caribbean: Curse of the Black
Pearl.
It just proves that old expression: it doesn't
matter how bad the movie is — you just can't
keep a good hat down.
Or...something.
Prince of garment thieves
Alan Rickman was a standout in whatever movie
he appeared in.
Take his turn as the villainous Sheriff of
Nottingham in the 1991 action/adventure Robin
Hood: Prince of Thieves.
He single-handedly saved an ill-conceived
project simply by being capable of speaking
with an English accent.
His outfits were no less extraordinary, particularly
this beaded piece of black armor that showed
up again in both the French film The Visitors,
and on the back of the Queen's advisor in
Braveheart.
Fashion hunter
When you're one of the fiercest bounty hunters
in all the galaxy, you need gear that won't
let you down.
That may be why Bossk — the Trandoshan bounty
hunter who appeared in a little movie called
The Empire Strikes Back — lifted his outfit
wholesale from an astronaut in a 1966 episode
of Doctor Who called "The Tenth Planet."
In fact, the suit originally came from the
Royal Air Force, who used it as a High-Altitude
Pressure Suit back in the '60s.
Come to think of it, there's nothing more
high pressure than taking on an angry Wookie.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!